okay here we are on CNN with our
panelists this week David Sedaris is
over here with his new book out
professor of marketing at New York's
CERN School of Business Scott Galloway
and the great writer for the Atlantic
Annie Lowry and here are the things that
people want to know about
um okay a group of conservatives
recently said they want to create an AI
chatbot of Their Own
to come that liberal bias can we well
I've heard there was liberal bias I
heard I've read that that chatbot is a
little woke uh
can we expect AI to be used as a
political weapon in the near future I
think it already is I mean it's funny
that you you create something that is
supposed to be smarter than everybody
and above it all and immediately we're
breaking down into you know we're gonna
that's what it's gonna be you're gonna
have the liberal chatbot and the
conservative right
yeah and there's submissive like
traditional media I think it's hard to
argue that there isn't oftentimes a
liberal bias because it's mostly
overeducated people in urban centers but
with respect to New Media and Technology
driven media there's no evidence that
there's any sort of bias they don't lean
left they don't lean right they lean
green they're all about money they
really don't care as a matter of fact
seven of the ten each day most viral
pieces of content are usually from
conservative commentators so there's
just no truth to the notion that at
least online media has a conservative
bias
hmm
I know people talking about liberal bias
excuse me oh all right
uh David is there any material you
wouldn't perform in red States oh um you
know I think I've heard you say this
before you know I would go to Oklahoma
and people say who was there and it's
like
everybody who didn't vote Republican is
there so I don't or that or some who did
I hope they all come I welcome everybody
in my and I'm sure you do too
uh I don't like it no
no I do I but I don't like you know like
sometimes you do a show and you get a
laugh from people and you think eh that
didn't feel right to me I don't want to
Pander to the audience no you know I
don't wanna so I'm happy to go to a red
state right and and quite frankly there
is more to make fun of on the left in
the last five years I mean I'm seeing I
see it in your book too you know people
ask me that all the time why do you make
fun of the left more because you're
providing comedy for a comedian
[Applause]
right all the cities are blue if you
just want to talk to Democrats you just
go to cities right regardless of the
state yeah right exactly I mean I've
Alabama
I've been I played Mobile Alabama yeah
the only thing you got to bring your own
hotel though
I one of the times I was in Alabama I
swear there was a bass fishing something
the same night and I was going out to
the show and on there was a Christ swear
to God there was a large crowd walking
one way that I could tell was for the
bass fishing
I won't go into details and then my
crowd was going in the opposite
direction and it could have been any
city in the country so I mean and that's
Alabama
okay what do you make of
G and Putin's meeting well boy they
exchanged friendship bracelets didn't
they
G and Putin I I'll you go you go first
but then I will tell you I think that's
the biggest and scariest news of the
week while we're all scared about
I don't know we're worried about trans
swimmers or worried about our kid
marrying a republican the real threat is
an Axis power forming between Russia and
China and it should be scared and they
are
China
you know China of of today is different
than China of 10 years ago and they are
they're not a competitor they're
adversaries and maybe even enemies the
swing boat will be India but we should
absolutely be it should have sent chills
down the spine of every American and
sing those two together well I I mean I
was mentioning on this
show that uh in the 20th anniversary of
the Iraq War yeah I think this is a
result of that
uh I think you know when well in the
sense that G and Putin see America they
saw 20 years ago we invaded a sovereign
country yeah I mean we we would make the
case that we had reasons that Putin
doesn't have in going into Ukraine but
that's not how they see it so their view
is and yes China and Russia never had
any love for each other even during the
Cold War when they were both Communists
and they should have been Allied closer
was very frosty but their idea is we
have to just be number one is to be
anti-American America is the one that's
trying to bully the world we've seen it
over and over again and we have to line
up against them that I think is the
scary part is because they're going to
get more people to join in on that
premise yeah and I think that there's
the Eternal Folly that Wars are won
quickly which we learned twice that that
wasn't true recently and I think that
the Russian engagement in Ukraine is
going to last for many many many many
many years to come weakening that state
considerably and it's terrifying I I
don't know okay a school principal at a
Florida school recently resigned after
parents complained that students were
shown Michelangelo's David
oh it's a nice sculpture
was it really appropriate or just an
example of parents being too fragile
about what their kids are taught in
schools went to was this parental had to
resign because he shut David is a great
worker or now yes the dick is out but
well it is and it was no bigger than the
students I was going to say it would
probably bolster the confidence of a
sixth grader yeah
I mean that's a very uh you know the
name of that statue should be it was
cold out
foreign
I serve on the board of my kids school
in Florida and the notion that we were
trying to pull the gay or the straight
out of them is just ridiculous we
schools aren't trying to turn kids into
worksters we're trying to turn them into
Warriors and these culture wars that
divide us and use schools As Weapons to
inflame some weird imaginary problem in
schools it's just it's another example
of instead of working on the things that
actually affect us people want to figure
out what offends us so they can raise
money it's a topic
on CNN watch your mouth oh sorry
keep keep your swear words out of your
mouth
uh you know the the southern strategy as
the most effective political strategy
that we've seen deployed in the United
States in the past hundred years and I
think that we're seeing Republicans
attempt to turn anti-trans legislation
anti-lgbtq legislation into a kind of
version of the southern strategy that
whips voters up and I think that it
remains to be seen how that you know
certainly in the midterms it didn't seem
to work terribly well but of course
what's at risk is the health and safety
of children and the rights of Americans
to live how they want and love who they
want so yeah it's awful
okay
uh okay Christian Kristen Cinema Kristin
or Kristen Kirsten okay Kirsten see I
got it Kirsten Cinema she's the senator
from Arizona she's now an independent
right she was elected as a Democrat but
uh was not quite Democratic enough for
the party uh or liberal enough so she's
an independent uh recently said she's
not going to eat in the cafeteria
anymore because it's just
old dudes eating jello
no well I'm telling you see aren't you
glad you're listening to this show you
know what I lost so much weight eating
diet Jello really
jello's great
I don't think that's the point she was
going for but but you know as a
tangential topic it's regular Jello like
calories in it yeah oh sure it's all
sugar like everything else but Donella
was 40 calories for the whole box and
you're feeling hungry and you eat two
boxes of jello and you're full and it's
80 calories Jello we drink it here on
CNN
[Applause]
any any thoughts on the old people
drinking Jello because you're I
think her what she was saying is that
our elected representatives are probably
not representative of America the
average of American is 38 the average
age of an elected representative of 64.
meaning every time someone like AOC is
elected to congress someone else is dead
I mean it's it's
three and what do you know cost of
living adjustment biggest in history for
Social Security recipients and the tax
credit the child tax credit gets
stripped out of the bill we don't have a
representative government we have
um basically people who are much older
running our government we need more
youth we have the second oldest elected
populace we don't have a representative
government
Cinema is one of the few politicians I
think on the hill who retains a capacity
to surprise and um you know
also kind of like to tell it like it is
I mean I don't maybe I don't think she
was making so much of a political
statement is just saying I don't want to
eat with Denny Hoyer yeah I think a lot
of members of Congress don't necessarily
want to sit down and eat with Chris
Kirsten cinema at this point either
but we love all politicians in this year
but we have to be mindful of
advertisements here on CNN so you nature
Jello and we'll see you next week
foreign